d'abord il faut un pilote dans l'avion
il n'y a pas de pilote aujourd'hui
hollande n'est pas un pilote mais
hollande est absent moi je suis effaré
d'abord vous l'avez entendu en réalité
n'a rien dit j'ai dit oui c'est grave
attention oui pour ça merci
il faut pas être président de la
république pour le dire moi je suis
effaré du fait qu'on arrive aux briques
site on se réveille ce matin avec la
gueule de bois on se dit au fond est-ce
que les grands dirigeants européens
avaient pris des positions fortes pour
tenter d'éclairer après tout le peuple
britannique nous la première fois que le
président de la république française a
parlé du bric site c'était il ya trois
semaines en inaugurant un tunnel en
suisse un tunnel en suisse il a fait une
déclaration
il faut le faire imaginez quand la
grande bretagne a voulu entrer dans la
communauté économique européenne à
l'époque il ya eu dix ans de débats en
france le général de gaulle était
président de la république il ya eu des
débats passionnés dans la classe
politique française
le président de république française n'a
pas évoqué la question du président
avant que le brésil ait lieu alors je
vous renvoie après papa par hasard à la
l'assemblée nationale ce mercredi à une
séance de questions au gouvernement qui
était dédiée à l'europe
pardon mais toute la classe politique
française dans ce cas n est pas à la
hauteur du débat sur l'europe
philippe juvin lorsque je la juste
plaisir on a vu quand vous êtes
président de la république vous êtes en
charge d'un intérêt supérieur c'est
celui de faire en sorte que la voix de
la france pèse en europe propos
forcément défendre des intérêts français
mais parce que il n'y a pas d'europe
s'il n'y a pas de moteur commun
franco-allemand
or depuis que françois hollande est
président de la république pardon il n'y
a plus il ya un effacement de la france
tel qu'il n'y a plus de moteur franco
allemand
donc la première chose à faire c'est ce
que juncker a dit il ya 10 messieurs les
français messieurs les anglais et
messieurs les débris et les lits
brittany les événements selon madame
l'allemand becker madame chaussures
mettez-vous tour notables et de nous
alors simplement